اعلن المركز السعودي لزراعه الاعضاء عن
انقاذ حياه خمسه مرضى بعد نجاح الفرق
الطبيه في نقل اعضاء شاب متوفى دماغيا
تبرع باعضائه قبل الوفاه المركز السعودي
اوضح ايضا ان الاعضاء التي تمكنت الفرق
الطبيه من زراعتها هي الكليتان والكبد
والرئه بالاضافه الى زراعه القلب
المركز السعودي لزراعه الاعضاء الدكتور
خالد الروقي دكتور خالد حياك الله ما يعرف
من الرياض وخلينا نعرف اولا تفاصيل قصه
هذا
المتبرع متى يعني تبرع الاعضاء استعرضناها
ربما ايضا قبل قليل لكن نريد تفاصيل اكثر
عن هذه الحاله هذه الحاله طبعا هي قصه
بطوليه الامانه يعني هي مثل مثل كثير من
حالات الوفاه الدماغيه تبدا بماسه لكنها
تنتهي بعطاء واعطاء اصلا حياه
لمرضى اخرين في الحاله هذه خمسه مرضى من
اعضاء من اللي عندهم فشل عضوي استفادوا من
اعضاء هذه المتوفي طبعا هي بدات الحاله
بدخول للمتوفي للمستشفى حاول اطباء انه
يعالجونه ينقضون حياته لكن قدره الله
بعد كذا وصلنا لبلاغ عن المركز
عمره تقريبا 33 سنه
في في وضع سليم للتبرع فهيدي الفتره
العمريه هذه السليم للتبرع في في حال ان
توفي دماغيه لا قدر الله صحيح مش بعد
الوفاه
صحيح حتى بالنسبه للاحياء يكون لانه يكون
زي ما انت عارف اليمين من الامراض المزمنه
في المركز على الحاله هذه اللي هي كانت في
مستشفى او مدينه
اللي هو مستشفى الحرس الوطني في الرياض
وصلنا البلاغ عن طريق وحده التبرع
بالاعضاء هناك موجوده انه في حاله اشتباه
وفاه دماغيه موجوده عندنا بدانا احنا
المتابعه صار فيه طبعا من الاطباء
المختصين شخصوا الحاله بتشخيص كامل سواء
بالفحوصات او تشخيص الكلينيكي واتموا
تشخيص الوفاه الدماغيه طبعا حسب المعايير
الانظمه المعمول فيها عن السعوديه اكتمل
التشخيص وصلنا الخطوه اللي بعدها الاهل
احنا قابلنا الاهل جلسنا مع اهل المتوفي
طبعا هو شاب الاب والام جلست معهم كذلك
اخوه واللي هو كان موجود في المملكه
والحمد لله احسن منهم على موافقه جد النبي
لو جدا مشكورين فيها الهدف منها انه تبرع
بالاعضاء
للمرضى رحمه الله عليه طيب
خليني اسال عن المركز اليوم عن اعداد
المسجلين حاليا في السعوديه بالتبرع
بالاعضاء كما وصلها للعددين الى الان
الحمد لله الى الان وصل العدد الى 500
وسبعه الف
متبرع او راغب بالتبرع اللي هم بعد الوفاه
وتاثر عليها اللي هو بطاقه المتبرع
يعني رقم رقم جدا جميل بس احنا نطمح باذن
الله ان يكون العدد اكبر بكثير ممكن نتكلم
عن 500,000 500 نعم كيف النمو في اعداد
المسجلين يعني انتم كيف رصدتوه خلال
الفتره الماضيه هل هل النمو متزايد
ومتسارع ولا في فترات مثلا متقطعه النمو
الحمد لله في تزايد
وخصوصا ودي اشيل الذكر انه بدايتها كانت
في 2021 في شهر رمضان كانت في مبادره
كريمه من اسمه سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
ولي عهده حفظهم الله انه كان عنده مبادره
بتسجيل كمتبرعين ورغبين كانوا اول
المقدمين في الرغبه والتبرع وطلع اثر
البطاقه ومن بعدها الناس بدات بدات تسجل
كمتبرعين وحمزه الارقام في تزايد بس باذن
الله تكون بتكون اعلى بكثير في السنوات
القادمه يعني من 2021 الى 2023 حنتكلم على
57,000 صح تقريبا شخص
الاحتياج الحالي اليوم لزراعه الاعضاء في
السعوديه او خليني اتكلم للحالات اللي
خلينا نقول تعاني من فشل عضوي في تقديرات
معينه لها عندكم اي موجوده انا ودي صراحه
اشرح الصوره هذي طبعا هو في ازدياد كبير
في المرضى اللي عنده فشل عضوي نهائي
وبالاخص الفشل الكلوي يعني كل واحد منا
ممكن يعرف شخص او شخصين عندهم مشاكل في
الكلى ويمكن يمرون بالغسيل في احد مراكز
الغسيل في نفس الوقت عندنا في زياده في
عدد المتبرعين لكن ما يغطي الحاجه
لمرضى الفشل العضوي يعني احنا عندنا حاجه
اكثر من عدد المتابعين بالضبط بالضبط مع
انه في ازداد في الارقام كلها فعلى سبيل
المثال انا بعطيك هم يقيسونها على عدد
المتبرعين في كل مليون نسمه عندنا في
السعوديه كان في 2021 وصل العدد او النسبه
الى
2.9% فئه 2.9 لكل مليون نسمه منهم يطلع
متبرع العدد في 2020 الى 3.5 طبعا لو
قررناها بدون مفترض يكون يعني لو قرنا
بدول العالم يوصلون الى عشره الى عن هدفنا
15% من مليون شخص 15
متبرع لكل مليون شخص فاحنا نضربها في عدد
النسمه النسمه الموجوده في البلد وتعرف كم
كم النسبه كم المطلوب احنا طبعا هدفنا
نوصل الى عشره من ثلاثه فاصله عشره اشخاص
من كل لكل لكل مليون متبرع لكل مليون
متبرع وفي طبعا الاحصائيه ثاني برضو تشرح
الصوره اللي هم عدد
عمليات الزراعه وطبعا هذا يشمل العمليات
في الاحياء واللي المتوفين احنا وصلنا الى
خمسين عمليه زراعه لكل
لكل مليون نسمه هدفنا نوصل فيها ان شاء
الله الى 65 عمليه وطبعا هذا شغله مهمه
جدا طبعا يشمل الاحياء والمتوفين وجديد
بالذكر انه المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولا
الحمد تعتبر المركز الثاني عالميا من
ناحيه المتبرين الاحياء
اعلى الدول في العالم تبرع في الاحياء من
المركز الثاني تعتبر المملكه هذا شيء جدا
جبار ان شاء الله تكون في المركز الاول
قريبا جزيل الشكر
الطبيب والمنسق الاكلينيكي في المركز
السعودي لزراعه الاعضاء الدكتور خالد
الروقي شكرا يا دكتور